today this independent maternity review  is publishing its first report  this is a report calling for immediate  action  it contains local actions for learning  for the maternity service at the trust  and immediate and essential actions for  consideration  by all maternity services in england  including  the trust since this independent review  started  its scope has grown from a review of 23  families  to now include 1 862 families  of cases occurring predominantly between  the years 2000  and 2019. there are a very small number  of families from earlier than 2000  where those early families have raised  very significant concerns with us  we have said that where maternity  records exist  our team will endeavor to answer those  concerns  you